all of my female heroes were Golden
Girls until I came across this way
well undecayed on Carlucci get embedded
by 2007 la la Sol la Sol la Sol en el
balcón Fiat remote Abed lol no clue
alright so just to set that up a little
better for you that is a Lebanese TV
show and obviously the host is stepping
up not only for herself but for all
women and women's rights which that part
of the world not doing that well when it
comes to women's rights this is a
beautiful thing yeah that guy made me
very angry
yeah wouldn't want it beneath me to be
talked to by a woman it's like excuse me
yeah it's hard to believe that that's
actually still going on this is 2015
yeah and it's a professional setting
it's what she does for a living you know
it's like a normal thing for guys to
come on the show and be interviewed by
her and what he thinks he's special or
something it's like yeah that's problem
shouldn't we give this girl major props
like this kind of went viral a little
bit but I feel like this is the type of
thing with everything going on in the
Middle East and women's rights just
disastrous all over the place like she's
really putting her stuff on the line
right there I mean and I think that's
half the problem why it hasn't gone
incredibly viral like to the next level
because I mean there's still a risk
factor for this woman's life right
feeling absolutely unfortunately I mean
I am kudos to him I mean I look up to
her tremendously that was very bold of
her I love how he literally is at a loss
for words
he literally pauses like way Hoda it was
just heaven and he
I said it like that how does credibly
good in bed and but and I am shocked
that she does she like have a private
like plug that she can pull cuz it seems
like she's just like saying yeah it
wasn't like production or anything like
that like she actually pulls his his
audio herself or she's got an audio that
it's just a chick probably the other
side um why are we so okay with women's
rights being so backwards in this part
of the world like I feel like if this
happened in Europe or something it
wouldn't be okay but over there or even
happen in America this would never be
okay to speak to women like that but we
we just allow it I don't know what we're
supposed to do as I say with all these
middle-east things not saying we should
do anything but like what can we do to
I'm okay I'm not okay with it yeah yeah
no that is what we can now yeah I mean I
think this is good that we're talking
about it yeah I mean it's kind of hard
to do anything else you don't really
have a lot of control over what they're
doing I think a lot people to see it as
the norm yeah yeah and I'm like well
that's just how it is over there and
they blow it off but I mean that's
totally not acceptable so I think the
only thing we can do is you know this
video on YouTube is awesome it's getting
millions of views that's awesome you
know and then we're talking about it
yeah so yeah shouldn't video rights
groups though be like like code pink or
whatever the other woman's right I know
code pink so it's all about war with
that but like shouldn't they be like
finding this woman and being like this
is gonna be the face of our new campaign
for women across the world absolutely
but I think she was right I think that
you know it's so it's thought to be such
the norm in that culture that a lot of
people in the United States and and in
Europe I think just think it's like
something that is built into their
religious constructs so they don't want
to mess with it or they don't know
enough to kind of challenge it which is
incorrect yeah this stuff like this make
you guys think like how good we actually
have it here like I know we're not quite
there on gay rights yet we're still not
there with women's rights with a lot of
things but like when you see things like
that really realize like it's pretty
good here right I mean it makes me think
it's pretty good at the same time I
don't want to think oh we've got it
pretty good I think that should just be
universally
well you just want full equality now I
agree and I feel like a lot of people
will use these types of situations to be
like well you shouldn't complain about
anything you have in the United States
because look how much worse it could be
yeah you know so I think that it's
important to like you know keep your
good perspective on everything and it's
important to talk about other countries
but also you know doesn't mean you need
to lose sight of problems we still have
here all right so I did a segment with
you a couple weeks ago at Roseanne's
about whether you are a feminist or not
so I'll start with you on this one
do you consider yourself a feminist I
mean in the literal sense if you look in
the dictionary and look up what feminism
is I would consider myself that I would
also consider myself more than a
feminist and egalitarian like I just
want to be considered a human who wants
equal rights and demands accords across
the board yes that was pretty solid yeah
I want to call out for that answer yeah
yes everyday that's pretty much what we
said in our video you know because like
by the dictionary definition of course
women's rights right why would you say
anything differently right but a lot of
times you know modern feminism things
have taken a weird turn and is turned
into this man-hating right culture which
I don't want identify with so that's
kind of there's a lot of reasons online
feminism isn't one of them right yeah
all right well what do you think are you
guys feminists should we take this woman
and really be making her sort of the
face of how we can change things in the
Middle East and for women's rights all
over the place to let us know in the
comments right now